[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de votre
fidélité à dimanche en politique sur
france 3 bourgogne
il est le premier parlementaire de
droite à avoir soutenu emmanuel macron
dans sa course à la présidentielle il
est aujourd'hui le seul élu bourguignon
membre du gouvernement d'edouard
philippe longtemps copéiste puis
juppéiste est donc désormais macro nist
l'ancien sénateur de l'yonne est il
vraiment à l'aise dans ses nouvelles
baskets on lui posera la question
les premiers mois du mandat du président
les chantiers de la majorité en 2018 son
ancrage local dans l'yonne et son avenir
personnel sont au programme de cette
émission dont l'invité donc jean
baptiste lemoyne bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères est
toujours conseiller départemental de
l'yonne le 21 juin dernier vous entriez
au gouvernement je vais vous demander
dans un instant quel bilan vous tiré de
ses premiers mois s'est un peu l'objet
de cette émission et puis on parlera des
futurs chantiers de la majorité mais
d'abord mélodies stevenson nous retrace
votre parcours
c'est une ascension fulgurante pour
jean-baptiste lemoyne
tout commence dans l'yonne en 2011 quand
il est élu vice-président du conseil
général
trois ans plus tard il poursuit sa
carrière en devenant maire de vallery la
même année il se fait élire sans
étiquette et accède seul mandat de
sénateur de l'yonne
à cette époque la commission nationale
d'investitures avait largement montré sa
préférence pour le candidat sortant
pierre bordier longtemps très proche de
jean françois copé pour lequel il a
travaillé comme collaborateurs
ministériels
jean-baptiste lemoyne fait finalement le
choix d' emmanuel macron et le soutien
pour l'élection présidentielle
il est d'ailleurs le premier
parlementaire heller a osé franchir le
pas et signe sa naissance médiatico
politique sur le plan national
une ascension qui prendra sens lors de
sa nomination en juin dernier
dans le second gouvernement d'edouard
philippe il est donc nommé secrétaire
d'état auprès de jean yves le drian
ministre des affaires étrangères depuis
sa nomination légumes a estimé à
plusieurs reprises que son ancienne
famille politique et l'eire n'avait plus
d'emploi
on va devenir vraiment à l'avenir dans
un instant des républicains mais
jean-baptiste lemoyne est ce que vous
regrettez ces sept derniers mois est ce
que vous êtes un ministre épanoui
heureux bien dans ses baskets d'avoir
choisi emmanuel macron vous l'homme de
droite à mais tout à fait bien et dans
les baskets et dans la tête parce que ce
qui se passe en france depuis
effectivement 7 8 mois est fantastique
souvenez vous il ya un an il ya un an
jour pour jour la france était dans une
sorte de dépression mentale
on se posait la question de quel est
l'avenir pour le pays pour pour de
nombreuses françaises et français et je
crois qu'il ya cette petite flamme de
l'espoir qui étaient ravivés par une
aile macron tout simplement avec
beaucoup d'idées concrètes pragmatiques
on essaye un peu d'oublier les
étiquettes politiques tout simplement
pour se consacrer aux résultats et vous
savez j'ai été effectivement plusieurs
années maire de vallery je suis toujours
aujourd'hui le monde du conseil
municipal donne aux communes rurales
quand on s'installe autour de la table
du conseil municipal on laisse ses
opinions j'irai partisane au vestiaire
et on veut une seule chose c'est
améliorer le cadre de vie amélioré le
fonctionnement de la commune et c'est la
même chose au niveau du gouvernement
ce que l'on souhaite sous l'égide du
présent la public du premie nice et
loire philippe c'est tout simplement
peut-être en finir avec un certain
nombre de tabous français et faire en
sorte que la france est bien elle puisse
rebondir et se projeter pleinement dans
ce monde qui est complexe
on le voit par un certain nombre de
crises et moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que je vois que la france allait
de retour je suis souvent l'étranger en
tant que secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères
et je vois que le regard sur la france a
changé et s'il a changé c'est parce qu'
un certain nombre est bien de
transformation ont été déjà initié
depuis que le présent dans le public à
entrer en fonction je pense notamment à
la réforme de la fiscalité à la réforme
du droit du travail et ce qui est je
crois une grande satisfaction c'est que
beaucoup à l'étranger se disent c'est en
france que ça se passe c'est en france
que ça bouge et qui des personnes qui
veulent investir qui veulent faire créer
des emplois en france
et tout cela bien ça sera pour le bien
des français à robinho on va revenir au
positionnement de la majorité à laquelle
vous appartenez désormais mais puisque
vous parliez de votre périmètre
ministériel l'actualité de la semaine a
notamment été marquée par le voyage des
manuels macron en chine avec au moins
une polémique le président de la
république n'a pas parlé des droits de
l'homme en public n'a pas abordé cette
question est ce que vous le secrétaire
d'état aux affaires étrangères vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi quelle
est la méthode dont il une parle
justement pour se défendre de ce choix
là aussi comme dans tout gouvernement ce
qui nous guide c'est l'efficacité
voilà on veut des résultats et
l'efficacité en matière de droits de
l'homme
c'est pas de faire des grandes
déclarations urbi et orbi le président
d'un public a dit je ne suis pas pour la
diplomatie de l'hygiaphone la diplomatie
du haut parleur mais c'est dans le cadre
des entretiens entre chefs d'état de
pouvoir passer un certain nombre de
messages de pouvoir signaler un certain
nombre de cas de situations qui nous
préoccupe est il qu'en privé il l'a fait
le président chinois vous pouvez nous
nous l'affirmé parce qu'il faut aussi
porter peut-être pas là est la
diplomatie de visafone mais quand même
la diplomatie des valeurs de la france
s'imagine bien sûr mais nous y sommes
très attachés et d'ailleurs l'assemblée
générale des nations unies le président
république réaffirme ses valeurs
fortement y est fortement soutenu
applaudi par de nombreux chefs d'état
lorsqu'il le fait et vous savez il le
fait mais il systématiquement avec tous
les chefs d'état avec lesquels on
considère que et bien il ya des
situations qui peuvent être
préoccupantes
ça a été le cas il ya quelques jours
également avec le scénario qu'avec
monsieur erdogan
exactement et on pense que c'est pâques
ont pensé qu on le sait cette méthode
elle est celle qui produit le plus de
résultats alors est ce que on ne peut
pas dire que c'est aussi en raison des
liens économiques avec la chine que
emmanuel macron a été un peu modérer
puisqu'on a vu les contrats signés pour
areva pour airbus est arrivé comme par
hasard pendant pendant le voyage même si
c'est sans doute des contrats qui se
prépare depuis très longtemps même avant
votre arrivée aux affaires
est-ce que là il n'y a pas un hiatus
dans la diplomatie
non vraiment le président un public
encore une fois il dit les choses il dit
les choses aux bons interlocuteurs au
bon moment et au bon endroit et le bon
endroit
c'est pas encore une fois des
déclarations fracassantes sur un plateau
c'est faire en sorte que ça s'adresse
aux bonnes personnes au bon moment il
donc la gérer les affaires économiques
et s'agissant s'agissant de de la
dimension économique
naturellement la chine est un pays qui
se transforme à vitesse grand v on voit
l'émergence d'une classe moyenne
vous savez que par exemple la chine est
désormais le premier pays émetteur de
touristes au monde avec plus de 130
millions de touristes est d'ailleurs la
france en accueil à 1,8 million vous
savez j'étais en charge du prix notre
région d'ailleurs tout à fait j'étais en
charge du tourisme dans l'yonne et tout
cela continuer à irriguer naturellement
et bien l'action maintenant que je porte
au niveau national dans ce domaine là
aussi et donc nous souhaitons
naturellement à pour atteindre les 100
millions de touristes en france en 2020
également doublé le nom je me trouvais
dans le noir pour me du coup il ne faut
pas froisser les dirigeants chinois
n'ont franchement pardon d'insister on
dit aux dirigeants chinois et bien les
situations qui nous préoccupe mais on le
dit pas comme ça face caméra
parce que ce n'est pas ça qui va
conduire aux meilleurs résultats nous ce
qui compte c'est le résultat regarder
que lorsque de vos confrères
journalistes étaient français était
emprisonné en turquie
voilà vous n'avez pas vu faire le tour
des plateaux en revanche vous avez vu
jean yves le drian un moment est bien
allé porter un certain nombre de
messages et on a vu que vos confrères
était revenu en france donc voilà c'est
ça qui compte
encore une fois c'est faire en sorte que
les choses soient dites mais surtout
qu'elles permettent de débloquer et
d'accélérer ces situations concrets pour
notre région sur le contrat d'areva donc
une usine de retraitement de déchets
nucléaires pour 10 milliards d'euros est
ce qu'on peut imaginer des retombées
dans notre région à la fois pour le site
du creusot et puis peut-être pour les
sous traitant d'areva qui sont nombreux
il est certain que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour l'industrie nucléaire
française et on sait que la saône et
loire notamment est particulièrement en
pointe dans ce domaine donc moi je me
réjouis qu'effectivement des retombées
auront lieu comme vous savez je
m'attache en tant que justement
secrétaire d'état aussi en charge du
commerce extérieur de faire en sorte que
à chacun des déplacements et bien je
puisse porter la parole d'un certain
nombre d'entreprises
de l'yonne ou de bourgogne et ainsi
lorsque par exemple au mois de décembre
j'étais en irak voilà une certaine
fierté d'avoir pu enfin obtenir la levée
de l'embargo sur la volaille française
parce que c'est un marché de 200
millions d'euros qui s'ouvre pour un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui sont
soit en bourgogne soit en bretagne et
tout cela c'est du concret pour le boeuf
aussi avec la chine
exactement c'est le président république
l'annoncé d'ici six mois
là aussi un nouvel embargo va être levé
et nous savons que nous avons besoin de
débouchés pour nos producteurs pour nos
éleveurs parce que on le sait c'est
parfois un peu compliqué mais là il ya
de nouveaux marchés qui s'ouvrent à
l'international et il faut s'en
féliciter vous n'étiez pas du voyage en
chine vous êtes pourtant le numéro deux
du quai d'orsay vous été puni non du
tout en fait moi j'ai préparé le voyage
donc j'ai fait un déplacement c'était
courant novembre pour préparer cela et
après vous savez nous nous répartissons
justement les rôles et les missions avec
jean yves le drian
c'est lui qui accompagne le chef de
l'état mais moi je serai à ses côtés à
dakar dans quelques jours pour justement
travaillé sur l'éducation l'éducation
des jeunes filles notamment
alors on va y venir à la suite de
l'actualité politique mais dans cette
émission très sérieuse on va sourire est
ce que vous n'étiez pas là bas parce que
vous vous préférez la diplomatie du
panda propose de regarder ces images
quand vous êtes rendus à beauval le 4
décembre avec brigitte macron c'est de
la diplomatie pour vous le panda c'est
très important pour la chine
et c'est vrai que à travers
et bien cet animal qui on le voit peut
être affectueux et parfois en même temps
un petit peu raide et bien il ya des
liens qui se nouent les premières dames
de france et de chine en sont les
marraines et ça fait partie
effectivement je dirais d'un cérémonial
et les symboles c'est très important
dans la vie diplomatique
je crois que la france et la chine sont
deux grands de grandes nations qui
puisent leur histoire dans les siècles
et millénaires
et donc voilà nous devons je dirais être
sensible à tous ces symboles et vous
savez le président république lui pour
sa part et bien offert un cheval de la
garde républicaine à son homologue et ça
peut paraître anecdotique
le panda mais je crois que de nombreux
français ont été touchés si j'en crois
le nombre de personnes qui m'en parlent
et qui sont sensibles aux cycles comme
premier ministre il faut savoir tout
faire un même allé rencontrer des pandas
mes services et moi on est là tout
simplement pour accomplir la mission et
dans la mission est bien il ya celle ci
paraît panda ça passe également par sa
dimension bon ça parle plus plus
sérieusement ça passe aussi par les
chiffres du commerce extérieur ils sont
tombés cette semaine ils sont mauvais
jean-baptiste lemoyne la france creuse
encore son déficit - 60 milliards
d'euros alors que l'allemagne
enregistrait l'annexé d'un an de 226
milliards en 2010 est un décalage
spectaculaire comment vous l'expliquez
en un mot et surtout comment vous pensez
y remédier alors explications je crois
que on est là aussi on paye 20 années de
désindustrialisation française vous le
savez
de nombreuses usines ont fermé sur notre
territoire est aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe c'est que lorsque la consommation
repart en france et c'est le cas parce
que l'activité économique est vraiment
dans une bonne une bonne direction eh
bien nous n'avons pas forcément la
capacité en france de répondre à cette
demande française et du coup ce sont les
importations qui augmente et donc par
conséquent toutes les mesures qu'a pris
le gouvernement sur l'attractivité du
pays sur le fait d'obtenir des
relocalisations d'emplois ça devrait
nous aider
et par ailleurs nous sommes en train de
travailler à un plan de soutien à
l'export qui sera dévoilée par le
premier ministre le 9 février prochain
ça sera l'occasion aussi de mettre un
peu d'ordre dans l'équipe de france de
l'export ce que vous savez il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs les chambres de
commerce business france les régions et
donc dans un jeu je conserve d'ailleurs
les présidents de région nous le
recevrons mardi prochain et donc nous
allons proposer enfin un guichet unique
qui va permettre et bien pour beaucoup
d'entreprises qui parfois hésite le pas
hésitent à se lancer dans l'export
d'avoir un contact et de pouvoir aller
plus facilement à l'étranger dans
l'actualité de la semaine jean baptiste
lemoyne ya aussi l annonce du premier
ministre de l'abaissement à 80 km/heure
de la vitesse maximale autorisée sur les
routes secondaires à double sens en
séparateur central soyons précis sera
effectif en juillet ça à diviser votre
majorité ces annonces est ce que vous
comprenez qu'il ya des voix qui
s'élèvent
pour dire que c'est pas la bonne
solution vous savez quand il s'agit
d'épargner des vies
je crois qu'il ne faut pas ménager ses
efforts et de ce point de vue là c'est
que l'yonne était expérimentatrice de
7,2 cette vitesse à 80 km/heure sur le
tronçon de la route qui va de dos erres
à clamecy et donc on a pu voir que ça
avait un impact très important sur la
chute de la mortalité et du nombre de
blessés - 87 % de tués sur ce tronçon
c'est vous dire que c'est très efficace
alors d'autres dans votre majorité ne
pensent pas comme vous et pourtant il y
avait une expérimentation aussi dans la
nièvre je vous propose d'écouter perrine
goulet député la république en marche de
la nièvre
elle n'est pas d'accord avec vous et
pour moi c'est pas la solution à la
baisse de mortalité
parce que quand on entend leurs
statistiques et en baissant la vitesse
de 10 km heure ont fait un gain de 4,6
pour cent de vie mais en réduisant donc
si on continue dans ses statistiques en
réduisant de 100 % on aura toujours 46 %
de morts donc voyez les celle-ci
couleurs faire ce qu'ils veulent mais
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que c'est une
décision prise par les gens qui vivent
dans les grandes villes qui sont pas
concernés par nos nouveaux territoires
de campagne et nous dans le territoire
mme à 80 km/heure ça va nous faire
perdre comme un certain temps et ce qui
a surtout c'est que pour moi à la
pratique c'est l'état des routes
c'est les comportements des personnes
c'est pas forcément la vitesse
d'ailleurs l'expérimentation du cv on a
une expérimentation dans la nièvre un
donc l'expérimentation a duré deux ans
de juillet 2015 à mars 2017
on s'est rendu compte que pendant cette
expérimentation il y avait eu un
accident corporel
alors que les deux années d'avant il n'y
avait pas l'expérimentation il ya eu
zéro
comme quoi d'avoir baissé de 10
kilomètres heure la vitesse sur ce
tronçon de route a créé un accident
alors qu'avant il y en avait pas sur les
deuxièmes d'avant bourse comme quoi
c'est pas c'est pas la solution
ce n'est pas la solution vous dis
perrine voulez écouter les chiffres sont
là ils sont sans ambiguïté mais le
gouvernement vous savez il a du coup
souhaité qu'il y ait une clause de
rendez-vous en 2020 et en 2020 et bien
justement ça sera l'occasion de voir
quels ont été les résultats de cette
mesure
et encore une fois on ne peut pas se
résoudre au fait que depuis trois ans le
nombre de morts sur la route à nouveau
augmenter vous savez moi je me suis
engagé dans la vie politique s'est
éteint en 2002 et le président jacques
chirac à l'époque déjà avait fait de ce
chantier de la sécurité routière une
priorité et on a vu qu'on a quasiment
divisé par deux le nombre de morts
encore une fois quand on voit les
conséquences
et je parle pas des blessés et qui
parfois je te mon avis est bien traîne
les séquelles de cela on ne peut pas se
résoudre cette situation autre sujet
autre couac dans la majorité celui qui
concerne les migrants et l'immigration
la loi projet de loi sur l'immigration
porté par gérard collomb est un des
chantiers de 2018 et la circulaire de
gérard collomb notamment sur l'accueil
inconditionnel dans les centres
d'hébergement fait polémique plusieurs
membres de la majorité se sont élevés et
même cette semaine les évêques de france
se sont opposés à cette circulaire en
demandant la sanctuarisation des centres
d'hébergement des écoles des hôpitaux et
des églises
quel est votre avis sur la question mon
avis est que l'on doit à la fois faire
en sorte que le droit d'asile qui est
réservé aux personnes qui fuient la
guerre qui fuient des persécutions
politiques ou religieuses et bien ces
personnes puissent avoir accès plus
facilement à ce statut de est bien de
réfugiés et de demandeurs d'asile dans
le temps où l'on dort il faut aller les
chercher dans les centres d'hébergement
et attendez c'est celles et ceux qui
sont éligibles à ce droit d'asile
eh bien vous savez que dans un souci
d'humanité il présente la république
justement il a souhaité qu'on leur
épargne cette traversée de la mort
qu'est la méditerranée et donc celles et
ceux qui sont éligibles qui sont dans
des pays de transit au niger ou au tchad
eh bien ils vont être avec la croix
rouge
ils vont être justement directement
acheminés dans les pays qui leur
procureront l'asile donc vous voyez seul
sou silimane d'asile ça fait l'unanimité
il n'y a pas de souci la question ce
sont les autres migrants est ce qu'il
faut aller les chercher dans les centres
d'hébergement selon vous comme le propos
gérard collomb c'est à dire aller
effectuer des vérifications dans les
centres d'hébergement est ce que c'est
le lieu pour le faire après le deuxième
sujet c'est effectivement la migration
de type économique
le fait est que un certain nombre
deux jeunes ne voit plus d'avenir dans
leur propre pays
c'est le cas dans de nombreux pays
d'afrique subsaharienne où les jeunes
font maintenant des études justement de
type licence maîtrise doctorat mais
derrière ne trouve pas forcément les
emplois adéquate et ça nourrit une
immense frustration
donc c'est pour ça que notre réponse
notre réponse elle est notamment en
matière de développement faire en sorte
qu' on puisse favoriser la création
d'entreprises de pme faire en sorte
qu'il ya derrière aussi exactement
c'est pour ça que il ya le souhait
affiché est la volonté ardente du chef
de l'état de faire en sorte que l'aide
au développement est que l'aide au
développement passe de 0 37% du pib à 0
55 % parce que on a besoin d'eux
d'offrir des perspectives et c'est la
règle et il n'y a pas de débat sur
l'aide au développement tout le monde
est d'accord et oui mais c'est ça la
réponse de long terme
oui il faut que je me lavais oui mais la
règle n ya pas de dmc est ce qu'il faut
aller dans les centres d'hébergement
pour opérer un tri dans les personnes
qui y sont j'emploie le terme à dessein
un tri et est du coup sélectionné est ce
que c'est bien le lieu vous voyez bien
qu'il ya un débat au sein de votre
majorité
ce matin dans un article dans le
parisien dans une interview gérard
collomb dit on ne changera pas notre nom
mais je crois que il faut présenter les
choses telles qu'elles sont il ya une
circulaire elle est appliquée avec
discernement et vous savez je trouve que
c'est pas la pétition need aiguë qui
permet d'apporter des solutions nous
encore une fois notre marque de fabrique
c'est le souci de l'efficacité faire en
sorte qu' il y ait en termes de droit
d'asile une meilleure efficacité là
aussi faire en sorte que les gens soient
vraiment éligibles et puis en termes de
migration apporter des réponses pérennes
cette association s'occupe des des sans
abri dans les centres d'hébergement fait
face beaucoup de pétitions elles sont
surtout au concret au concret du terrain
je vous propose de passer à un autre
sujet jean baptiste lemoyne vous l'avez
sans doute lu dans les colonnes du
quotidien la croix il y a quelques jours
publié le 3 janvier un sondage ifop six
français sur dix se prononcent en faveur
de la légalisation de la procréation
médicalement assistée pour les couples
de femmes un bond de presque 40 % depuis
1990 l'opinion évolue sur cette question
on sait que ça va être un dossier de
des prochains mois du gouvernement ça a
été évoqué lors de la campagne des
manuels macron à l'époque vous vous
aviez été jean baptiste lemoyne un
opposant farouche à la loi taubira à
l'époque pour le mariage pour tous
est ce que cette question elle va
diviser la majorité quelle est votre
point de vue sur la pma ouverte aux
couples de femmes on voit que c'est la
société française évolue à ce que vous
même vous avez évolué je crois que le
souci du président la république c'est
de faire en sorte que ce débat sur des
questions qui sont très sensibles qui
touchent à l'intimé qui touche à
l'éthique
puis ceux du rude dans les meilleures
conditions et à l'époque d'ailleurs il
avait signalé que lorsqu'il y avait eu
les débats que vous évoquez peut-être
cela n'avait pas été t-il bien organisés
et donc aujourd'hui il y à un comité
national d'éthique qui travaillent qui
justement auditionnent les représentants
des religions qui repré qui auditionnent
les les universitaires et je crois que
ça permettra justement de bien poser les
termes du débat et sur ce sujet je crois
que il ya énormément de sujets connexes
il faut évoquer parce que vous savez ce
qui est parfois en jeu c'est aussi pour
les personnes qui sont nées de ce type
de technique
quelque part une interrogation aussi sur
et bien leur filiation est donc le
souhait parfois de vouloir accéder de
vouloir accéder
eh bien peut-être à l'identité sens du
film est donc vous n'avez pas changé
d'avis fondamentalement sur ces
questions là mais parce que j'ai du
gouvernement que j'ai eu deux mois pour
ino dire le droit
je vous porterez une voie différente au
sein du gouvernement ce que je vais vous
savez au gouvernement je dire on assume
tout de a à z moi j'ai appuyé emmanuel
macron sur la base de son projet cette
mesure était dans son projet et donc son
projet je le défends de a à z donc vous
allez rouler sur laquelle ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce sont des sujets qui
sont justement très complexe et sur
lesquelles il faut ouvrir toutes les
portes tous les chantiers y compris
peut-être celui de l'accès aux origines
alors on sent que évidemment là dans la
majorité il y aura sans doute des
divergences entre ceux qui viennent
plutôt de la droite ceux qui viennent
plutôt de la gauche avec un un corpus
idéologique parfois différent je vous
propose de regarder cette citation
signée manuel valls dans le jeu
du dimanche la semaine dernière le point
d'équilibré de la majorité est au centre
gauche alors que celui de l'exécutif est
au centre droit le risque de désaccord
vient de là c'est ce qui expliquait
l'ancien premier ministre de françois
hollande au jdd est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
vous qui êtes un homme de droite sur le
fait qu'il ya le point d'équilibré n'est
pas le même au gouvernement et dans la
majorité parlementaire inde emmanuel
macron je crois que réfléchir en termes
de droite de gauche de centre extérieur
est quelque chose qui est un peu dépassé
je voulais dit aujourd'hui la
méthodologie demel macron c'est mettre
autour de la table est bien celle de
ceux qui ont envie de faire quand envie
d'agir et qui veulent tout simplement je
dirais mettre en oeuvre les meilleures
idées du bien de rihanna que ça peut
tirer sur la question de l'immigration
c'est la question de la pma ça peut
tirer un peu mais c'est que le premier
ministre edouard philippe
effectivement nous faisons la même
famille politique eh bien il anime cette
majorité parlementaire avec brio et ça
se passe très bien c'est très fluide
entre les députés de la république en
marche et le premier ministre et donc
moi je ne vois pas de hiatus ou de
couacs au contraire je vois beaucoup un
goût fort renouvellement et des femmes
et des hommes qui ont envie de porter
leur part de vérité c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait bien à droite
votre ancienne famille politique jean
baptiste lemoyne laurent wauquiez a pris
la tête de votre ancien parti les
républicains comment est ce que vous
regardez sa méthode et sa ligne
aujourd'hui je m'adresse aussi au
secrétaire d'état à l'europe parce que
on a vu que il avait choisi une ligne
plutôt eurosceptiques en prévision des
élections européennes
si vous voulez ce que je constate c'est
que en 2000 veut lorsque l'union pour la
majorité présidentielle a été créée
cette ump c'était la fédération deux
centristes de libéraux de gaulliste et
donc ça parlait à beaucoup de monde dans
la société
quinze ans plus tard ce qui est
malheureux c'est de voir que ce large
rassemblement en fait n'existe plus les
centristes et bien ont quitté cette
famille les libéraux dont j'étais
également est donc aujourd'hui on est
sur un petit noyau qui je pense n'a pas
la capacité de porter une parole qui
soit fédératrice pour la france et les
français parce que la france élite
diverses parce que la france a les ailes
et rurales et urbaines
elle et elle est la france périphérique
ça vous inquiète donc et dont votre
ancienne famille identique c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'on a besoin d'une parole
qui soit une parole à la fois apaisées
mais qu'ils aillent aux résultats et le
chef de l'état d'ailleurs dans sa
cérémonie de voeux nous a incités à
l'action il nous l'a bien dit ne vous
écoute ne vous habituer pas et bien au
ne vous habituer pas pardon à toutes les
impatiences des français il faut que
vous y apporter des réponses
le plus rapidement possible
jean-baptiste lemoyne vous êtes
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères et à l'europe
est ce que votre avenir politique pour
être d'aller au front dans cette
bataille des élections européennes en
2019 c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
vous intéresser si le président la
république vous le demander alors
franchement pardon mais là aussi c'est
très ancien monde on n'est pas là pour
se projeter pour un poste ou quoi que ce
soit on est pleinement à la tâche
pleinement la mission et ont six des dix
voilà 24 heures / oui mais justement
c'est la détention de défendre une
certaine vision de l'europe celle
d'emmanuel macron c'est pour ça que je
me pose la question
tout ça pour être dans le cadre d'une
élection est verrouillé je serai de
celles et de ceux qui naturellement
porteront un message fort pour les
élections européennes mais je n'ai pas
vocation à être candidat à toutes les
élections ce qui compte c'est encore une
fois d'agir d'oublier les ambitions des
uns et des autres mais parce que tout
simplement les françaises qu'ils
attendent c'est des résultats alors on
arrive au terme de cette émission
l'yonne est-ce que ça restera votre
terre d'élection ou bien est-ce qu'à
l'image d'un benjamin griveaux par
exemple vous verriez bien élu dans la
capitale la prochaine norme et attendez
je dois tout à l'yonne
il n'est pas un instant dans la journée
où je ne pense pas au département vous
le savez je suis toujours conseiller
municipal à vallery toujours conseiller
départemental dans le gâtinais avec
delphine grémy et je peux vous dire que
au quotidien dans mon action de ministre
les expériences que j'ai pu avoir dans
l'yonne elle continue et bien à
m'inspirer et les échanges que j'ai avec
de nombreux élus ou citoyens de l'yonne
notamment avec cette période de voeux à
bussy-en-othe à chaumont ou adoma tout à
l'heure eh bien ce sont des choses très
utile qui me permettent de dire au chef
de l'état ressenti ça les touche aussi
notre sens ça sert lieu aussi et est
donc ça ça peut servir l'yonne moi je
m'y attache par exemple lorsqu'il des
inquiétudes sur le maintien de
l'hélicoptère d'urgence à auxerre j'ai
tout de suite saisi agnès buzyn mme
agnès buzyn ahmadi il n'y a pas de
problème il ya une situation qui
justifie le maintien cet hélicoptère est
donc naturellement je suis là pour aider
le département aujourd'hui le leader de
la république en marche
en bourgogne s'appelle quand même un peu
françois patriat est ce que vous c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresseraient
de prendre le leadership de la
république en marche en bourgogne
pardon mais on a laissé ancien monde
aussi aller mais oui mais parce que moi
françois patriat c'est bien c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment je suis
pleinement dans ma tâche vraiment de
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères et dieu sait que il ya
beaucoup à faire parce que vous savez la
france elle est attendue sur de nombreux
chantiers internationaux de nombreuses
critiques ont donc voilà m'en voudrais
sera là il posait pas la question
vous savez que les personnels de
l'audiovisuel public sont inquiets
jean-baptiste lemoyne est ce que pour
vous le dis au visuel public c'est la
honte de la république à mes
l'audiovisuel public je le vois sur le
territoire et bien comme aujourd'hui une
permet de porter connaissance à nos
concitoyens et bien des politiques des
opinions des uns et des autres et donc
je crois que la réforme qui va être
conduite elle permettra de conforter
consolidé aussi l'audiovisuel public
dans un monde qui va très vite
merci d'avoir répondu à ces questions
devraient accepter cette invitation ce
dimanche dans un instant l'actualité
régionale avec elle a besoin et dimanche
en politique la suite avec francis
letellier très bon dimanche
[Musique]